[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is it it's finally here the well
talked about heavily rumored 16 inch
macbook pro has arrived
so i think the most interesting thing
about this laptop is that it's replacing
the 15 inch macbook pro it's not going
alongside the 15 inch and then the other
sizes this is the new biggest macbook
pro and its slotting in at the same
starting price that the 15 inch macbook
pro did but with some obvious and market
improvements so these are my first
impressions of those improvements so the
design first of all as you can see is
pretty much exactly the same same
footprint as a 15 inch macbook pro same
for USB type-c ports but its 0.77
millimetres thicker and a quarter of a
pound heavier its 4.3 pounds same space
grey but it now comes with space grey
stickers now so that adds to the total
confusion about which Apple devices come
with which stickers but the main
difference now of course as you can tell
by the name is the new 16 inch display
really is just modernizing the look of
the laptop by pushing out the display
from 15 inches to 16 inches and that's a
bigger canvas for everything you already
do on the laptop that gives you a new
resolution of 3072
by 1920 so that's the same pixel density
of 226 PPI same brightness 500 nits same
p3 color gamut but just imagine
basically pushing more of that display
outward to shrink the bezel and give you
more screen real estate that's the
biggest major change and I love that now
with this bigger display if you take a
look at Apple's site you may also notice
there's somehow claiming 11 hours so an
extra hour of battery life so if you're
wondering how they did that it's because
the extra tiny bit of thickness combined
with improved battery chemistry allowed
them to fit a new hundred watt hour
battery in the 16 inch MacBook Pro fun
fact and some of you fellow video makers
may know this 100 watt hours is the
largest physical capacity lithium-ion
battery you're allowed to get on a plane
with in the United States per the TSA so
they kind of maxed that out and I'm
pretty sure there are other laptops with
hundred watt hour batteries but that
doesn't mean they can't keep improving
the battery
they can still do things like improve
the chemistry and density to make it
smaller and lighter but that is a pretty
good point for the MacBook Pro to also
improve battery life I kind of like this
new Apple trend of doing better with
battery in 2019 that's the biggest
battery they could fit in the MacBook
Pro it'll also come with a more powerful
96 watt USB type-c charger and that
charger is also in the same footprint as
the previous generation so then there is
the keyboard so this is one of the
sticking points of the last MacBook Pro
that butterfly mechanism didn't do so
hot there's some new things with this
keyboard and by new things I mean also
kind of old things so they're going back
to this scissor mechanism for the
switches from the years of like the 2015
MacBook Pro they're more reliable
they're more clicky they have a little
bit more travel it's almost as if going
back in time is actually kind of an
upgrade here but it's not exactly the
same as previous generations it's really
kind of a hybrid in-between it's still
low travel about one millimeter of
travel but it's more stable than
butterfly keys where they're calling it
the new magic keyboard so very Apple
there's also now a dedicated Escape key
which pros were asking for and just
normal people like me too because the
escape button on the touch bar froze so
much that it was almost useless so thank
God that's back and there's also now a
bespoke separate touch ID unlock sensor
and it's a physically clicking button as
well to turn on and off the computer and
then performance is also a bump up so
you might recall that was also kind of
an issue last year you might remember
the thermal throttling issues with the
i9 MacBook Pro this is also improved
there are Intel ninth Gen 6 core and
eight core CPUs again in this laptop and
new fans and a new internal layout will
improve air flow by 28% and here are the
new specs still current gen stuff as you
can tell and you might notice it goes up
to 8 terabytes of internal storage now
and up to 64 gigs of ram so definitely
gonna have to do some testing to see if
this new spec can do the heavy lifting
that I require for my mobile video
workflow but we'll see also a little
nugget of news today alongside this new
MacBook Pro is the new Mac Pro is
officially coming out in just
number at some point alongside the pro
display XDR and that will also support
up to 8 terabytes of internal storage
nice then there's also some smaller
things that they've changed with this
refresh the speaker system there's a new
6 speaker speaker system and the
speakers in the MacBook Pro have been
from what I've experienced
top-of-the-line in a laptop for a while
now so I shouldn't really be too
surprised by this but these speakers are
really good like I said it's a new
system with redesigned subwoofers that
are now physically connected to each
other so that they cancel out the force
that they would have applied to the
chassis so they don't rattle as much
they're called forced canceling again
doesn't matter what it's called but they
are good stuff
[Music]
so yeah like I said best speakers in a
laptop around right now and they also
included what they call a studio quality
microphone and they call it that because
the new hardware of the microphone array
has a much improved signal-to-noise
ratio but I'll let you be the judge of
it how does it sound
honestly I think it sounds pretty good
not necessarily as good as they made it
sound like I could record a podcast with
this but nevertheless I'm happy to see
audio improvements and this is pretty
great this is awesome for video calls
and quick casual videos like this I
would have liked to have seen a video
improvement with the webcam too but they
didn't do that either way that's pretty
much it you can tell by the length of
the video it's a pretty small refresh
there's not a whole ton going on it's
still the same you know design same huge
trackpad same ports but it's more of a
refresh on a better ideal 2019 MacBook
Pro so I will say because this is my
first impressions and it's not my full
review yet I've got a lot of laptops to
review right now but this is my new
favorite MacBook Pro mostly because of
the design and the display this is a
laptop I'm most likely to carry to edit
with but what I would actually love to
see now is a 14 inch MacBook Pro in the
same footprint as the current 13 inch
MacBook Pro so update that 13 inch with
new specs but also slim down the bezels
and sort of modernize that too that
would be sick that would be my favorite
MacBook Pro that they could make anyway
I'm about to get on a plane to go to
that Motorola event that's tonight and
we'll see what they announce probably a
folding phone and we'll bring this
laptop with me and see if I can edit
that video on this laptop and I'll see
how it goes I'll tweet how it goes so
thanks for watching this first
impressions and first look at the 16
inch MacBook Pro add it to the docket of
videos that need to turn into reviews by
the end of the year but it's coming soon
get you guys in that time base
[Music]